des records de chaleur ont été battus
aujourd'hui la canicule a fait mûrir les
fraises trop rapidement 28 degrés au
dessus des normales toute cette pluie
qui complique la vie les agriculteurs et
si on perdait tous les grains de ce
champ de blé et c'est tous les fruits je
l'est où se dessécher sur les plans
j'étais bouleversée c'est vraiment le
mot que choisit parce que les arbres
étaient morts sur pied de la sécheresse
c'est ni plus ni moins une révolution
alimentaire qui doit se passer on veut
doit payer plus cher donc rude touchant
à chaque jour il ya un un grave état
d'urgence
les changements climatiques la nature se
déchaîne et entraîne des bouleversements
qui ont des répercussions directes dans
notre assiette
notre venue est ce que nous mangeons se
modifie
[Musique]
pour sylvia roth du laboratoire
d'économie écologique l'agriculture a sa
part de responsabilité
l'agriculture est un défense primaire
dans les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est contre lui à peu près un
quart 25% de tous les gaz émis chaque
année
pour catherine pots-de-vin biologiste le
lieu de culture à son impact
quand on mange des fraises qui arrive de
qu'elle fournit ou des épinards qui
viennent du chili
on mange pas juste l'épinard on mange
aussi les émissions de cet avion là qui
le transportait dans notre assiette
voilà il ya un cycle là qui se fait
entre nos décisions qu'on consommateurs
la maison au super marché et ce qui aura
dans le futur dans le même supermarché
c'est dans la serre tropicale du jardin
botanique de montréal que l'on rencontre
à l'incurie ethnobotaniste qui
constatent les changements sur le
terrain certainement des variétés qui
m'ont disparaît de nos assiettes c'est
plutôt moyen terme pour dans l'immédiat
on peut penser à des variétés de tomates
qui font moins mis sous la chaleur des
éléments qui demande une présence de
plus fort donc il a comme c'était
prévisible c'est plus difficile de jouer
ce facteur là c'est qu'on va être
confronté c'est que à chaque année la
disponibilité des produits variés
beaucoup alors on avait une année où
peut-être y avait une maladie avec les
arrange ils vont devenir trop cher on va
aller plus trouvé vraiment dans les
supermarchés mais peut-être deux ans
plus tard il sera là de nouveau mais les
frais seront affectés alors ceux qui
composent nos assiettes va changer je
pense vraiment d'année en année ça va
sonner un peu un peu plus cher que ça va
ça va vraiment dire tomber le moniteur
sur les consommateurs
des phénomènes qui vont s'accélérer et
devenir plus fréquent surtout que le
canada se réchauffe deux fois plus vite
que la planète quand personne ne peut le
dire mais des aliments soeur en moins
disponibles et parfois aussi auront un
goût différent on parle de des faits
plus dirait sur la qualité des aliments
par exemple sirop d'érable donc au
québec et aux états unis
on sait que le taux de sucre votre
minuit
les valeurs nutritives pourrait même
être modifiée par la chaleur par exemple
le pouvoir antioxydant
il pourrait pour certaines plan qu'une
baisse de qualité à ce niveau là donc
moins de bienfaits pour la santé des
gens liés au changement climatique on le
vus nous dans les travaux qu'on a fait
sur des plantes indigènes jusqu'à des
aliments de tous les jours transformer
en produits de luxe comme le café le
café comme espèce à une tolérance
vraiment limité en terme de température
il croit plutôt dans les montagnes
nuageux entre 1000 2000 mètres mais déjà
on est au sommet il ya plus d espace
pour monter pour cette production de
cette espèce
mais ça se peut que ça va devenir de
plus en plus rare dans les supermarchés
et puis ça va devenir vraiment un
aliment de luxe peut-être te prendrais
pas tes trois tasses par jour ça va
dépendre l'assiette de qui la signe des
richesses changera probablement pas
parce que il ya va avoir des personnes
qui va avoir un pouvoir économique puis
vont être capable de s'acheter des
produits plus difficiles à cultiver
plus inquiétant encore les
pollinisateurs qui disparaissent ou qui
changent leur cycle de vie
ils ne sont plus synchronisé avec les
plantes pour produire les fruits comme
les bleuets sauvages ou les pommes
produire une alimentation selon coline
tough d'équiterre les cultures ne sont
pas toujours efficaces il faut être
efficace dans le mode de production
ça veut dire tout ce qu'on cultive doit
être efficace tant sur le plan
environnemental que sur le plan de la
nutrition comme la production de kilos
de boeuf comprend à peu près 25 à 30 kg
de gaz à effet de serre pour la
production
bien que le poulet c'est seulement cinq
lancers cinq fois plus pollué à manger
de boeuf que le poulet alors c'est pas
nécessairement d'éviter tout le viande
de devenir végétalien mais de penser
qu'il ya des quelques produits de nos
alliés dans notre régime alimentaire qui
ont un impact fort sur l'environnement
en effet on mange encore beaucoup trop
de viande
une nouvelle étude de hitler cet
recommande pas plus de 100 g de boeuf
par semaine soit l'équivalent d'un petit
steak ou des hamburgers
on vous invite ce soir une réflexion
collective sur notre alimentation
ici à la maison du développement durable
une conférence a pour thème sauver la
planète commence dans son assiette
on tente de sensibiliser les gens à la
problématique
ben moi j'ai l'impression ne jamais en
savoir assez sur le sujet je me dis que
moi individuellement je pourrais
peut-être apporter quelque chose qui
pourrait aider la planète
je vais essayer de lutter de consommer
des produits qui sont pas de saison
l'habitude qu'on a eu vraiment de se
tourner vers les tomates les concombres
et toute la berd sûrs qu'ils sont des
produits qui viennent d'ailleurs c'est
assez récent finalement il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça
il y avait cette idée qu'on pouvait
manger les légumes racines qu'on pouvait
manger des concerts et ses façons de
faire doivent revenir pour qu'on ait une
alimentation plus locale qui a moins
d'impact
dans le grand nord chez les inuit
monsieur curiae a constaté que les
changements sont commencés c'est assez
troublant de voir comment tout se
changent rapidement dans leur milieu
un père gilles soldes qui commencent à
complètement enfants il ya les baies qui
ont pas le même goût la moelle des
cailloux qui a pas le même goût non plus
des maladies qui s'accroît chez les ch
et l'effort tout ça c'est un fait c'est
une sonnette d'alarmé
jusqu'à présent si nous les humains on
fait notre travail puis qu'on réduit nos
émissions
la nature vont nous aider pied avons
nettoyé mais si on continue à pousser
sur la nature puis à réchauffer la
nature est là pour pulpe remplies elles
vont se mettre à émettre et là c'est le
point de non retour
[Musique]
oh